[Music]
states of emergency in Quebec on this
Tuesday night we're trying to step ahead
the torrential rains the flood ravaged
regions and how people are coping
allegations the Chinese government
targeted a conservative MP there's a
member of parliament in this house whose
family has been threatened because of
the way he voted here the claims the
Prime Minister failed to take action
war of words
the Hollywood drama sending writers on
strike and what it means for your
favorite shows
and a sole-soothing Canadian Legend
forever silence
[Music]
Gordon lightfoot's immeasurable Legacy
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser good
evening thank you for joining us tonight
we begin in Quebec where after days of
heavy spring rain the province is now
dealing with the dramatic consequences
of severe flooding hundreds of residents
have been forced from their homes as
local Crews try to repair critical
infrastructure this section of Highway
138 in Bay Saint Paul is completely
washed away and two firefighters are
still missing tonight after they were
Swept Away by Rising river waters during
a rescue Mike Armstrong has more in our
top story tonight
there is the devastation you can see and
the devastation where people haven't
been allowed back yet some areas in Bay
St Paul are still off limits
this man says he hasn't absorbed the
shock he hasn't even seen the damage yet
locals say the water Rose quickly places
where people thought flooding would
never be a problem were underwater in
minutes two firefighters are missing
they just rescued two people airlifting
them to safety when they themselves were
Swept Away
Provincial Police say Searchers are in
boats in the air and on land looking for
the two men
over 48 Hours the Charlevoix region was
hit by 75 to 100 millimeters of rain
higher terrain where there was still
melting snow got even more everybody is
secure right now but we're still we may
have we may have again some
precipitation some rain for the next 24
to 48 hours
other regions have been hit hard as well
in Quebec's Leno di region Northeast of
Montreal culverts were Swept Away
damaging roads and cutting off some
neighborhoods
around Montreal the rain came quicker
than expected levels have been
threatening for weeks so far the
preparations have worked the dikes are
already built since two weeks sandbags
are in a lot of houses got their
sandbags so we are ready but it's more
than expected that's for sure
the city of Gatineau is warning
homeowners in low-lying areas it expects
water levels to rise there will be
trouble in some areas but it says it
should still be considerably lower than
the historic flooding in 2019
Mike Armstrong Global News Saint
Alphonse Rodriguez
Alberta's election campaign entered its
first full day today with both Rachel
notley and Danielle Smith in
Battleground Calgary exclusive polling
by ipsos for global news shows that
Smith's United conservative party has a
slight Edge over the NDP
48 percent have decided and leaning
voters say they would vote UCP compared
to 44 support for the NDP
for more on this we're joined by
Global's safe Kaiser from Calgary safe
it's still early days but this is
shaping up to be a very tight race
a very tight race indeed for us so only
four points separate the UCP and NDP now
that's very strong a very stark contrast
to the 2019 pre-writ draw polls we saw
where the UCP were much more ahead of
the NDP so pretty evenly matched this
time around while the NDP do have a
stronghold in Edmonton 11 points over
the UCP there the rest of Alberta is
being dominated by the United
conservatives and what really is going
to determine who forms the next
government is how calgarians vote
some of the main issues the leaders are
focusing on so far
well what we've seen throughout the
pre-election period here is that both
UCP and NDP supporters pretty much are
focusing on the exact same thing and
that's cost of living and improving the
Health Care system and again with
Calgary kind of being the Battleground
which will decide who forms the next
government uh one of the main issues
Calgary's facing is actually an issue
being seen in Edmonton as well and
that's public safety especially in the
downtown area we've seen numerous
announcements coming out of the NDP
numerous announcements coming out of the
UCP campaign promises on how they would
solve Public Safety a couple of
interesting points also highlighted in
this in this in this poll that we're
seeing here is the fact that while half
of albertan's surveyed say it's time for
a new party to take over a third of
albertan surveyed say that they believe
Danielle Smith has done a good job and
deserves to be re-elected and when we
look at this sort of as a leader versus
leader type situation both Smith and
notley again evenly matched to 35
percent say Smith would make the better
Premiere while 35 percent say notley
would make the better premier pharah
see if that Gap Narrows in the coming
weeks safe Kaiser in Calgary thank you
prime minister Justin Trudeau said today
he personally phoned a conservative MP
to reassure him and offer him a security
briefing this in the wake of Revelations
first reported by The Globe and Mail
that Michael Chong was targeted by the
Chinese government after he voted to
condemn China's treatment of its uighur
minority in February of 2021.
prime minister's government knew about
it and did absolutely nothing why that
is simply not true I spoke with a member
for Wellington Alton Hills earlier today
ensured that he got a briefing from our
top security officials to ensure that he
gets all the information he needs
the globe also reported cited csis
documents that Chong's family members in
Hong Kong were targeted by Beijing and
that a diplomat here in Canada played a
role in this alleged harassment as our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken explains the explosive allegations
dominated question period
[Applause]
Michael Chong Rose to the Applause of
his colleagues when was the public
safety minister or his office
first made aware that a PRC Diplomat Mr
Way Joe
was targeting me or my family he found
support from that Minister I want to
express solidary to him and to his
family and that we will continue to work
with him and all parliamentarians to
make sure that he and all
parliamentarians get the support that
they need but neither Chong nor other
opposition MPS got the answers they were
looking for this is a question of the
gravest importance
there's a member of parliament in this
house whose family has been threatened
because of the way he voted here
how can we defend National Security on
the floor of This House of Commons if
our family members are threatened based
on the votes that we cast the Prime
Minister knew about this and did nothing
frankly I'm disappointed but the PM and
his Public Safety Minister rejected the
opposition's line of attack to suggest
that anyone in this house would see a
threat to a colleague and simply sit on
it is Unworthy of parliamentary Mr
Speaker this is not a partisan issue we
must all work together to defend the
institutions the communities and most
importantly the parliamentarians who
serve those institutions to protect our
democracy the conservatives weren't
buying it what a gutless response what
if that happened to that Minister's
family to the gutless minister when did
they find out and eventually the speaker
had to intervene unparliamentary
language is not welcome in the chamber
calling people names is not permitted
now the PM said he spoke to Chong
personally and has asked thesis
officials to investigate the political
temperature though is unlikely to cool
anytime soon tomorrow the opposition
will try to connect the dots between the
Trudeau family the Trudeau foundation
and China when the prime minister's
brother and Trudeau Foundation board
member Alexandra Trudeau gives his
testimony at the House of Commons Ethics
Committee pharah David Aiken in Ottawa
thank you for that David
get ready for reruns late night shows
will be dark tonight as Hollywood
writers are officially on strike for the
first time in 15 years and this time the
strike revolves around streaming's
seismic shift in the entertainment
industry the people who script TV and
film say they're not being fairly
compensated in this rapidly changing
industry and the new AI era is
threatening their jobs Jackson prosco
reports
trading laptops for picket signs about
11 000 Hollywood writers walked off the
job halting production of TV shows and
jeopardizing film shoots late night
shows will start airing reruns
immediately I had no a show without my
writers The Writer's Guild of America
says its members face an existential
crisis over wages streaming services and
the future use of artificial
intelligence in script writing the guild
says half of its members now work at
minimum salary up from one-third a
decade ago I also think that the
writer's demands are not unreasonable
I'm a member of The Guild I support
collective bargaining Studios argue
their budgets are stretched and revenues
are falling the alliance of motion
picture and television producers said it
offered the writers generous increases
in compensation and is willing to keep
negotiating nobody disagrees that
writers in Hollywood are underpaid right
now there's a tremendous amount of
content but they're not getting the
compensation they want for it streaming
is the biggest issue dozens of services
have fractured the landscape streaming
platforms typically commission fewer
episodes of shows than Network TV
meaning less overall income for writers
the writers are essentially is saying
that the streaming landscape needs to be
updated and so the very future of the
entertainment industry hangs in the
balance the last writer strike in 2007
lasted 100 days it led to a surge in
unscripted reality programming and
spurred demand for foreign shows in the
U.S I do expect some Canadian series to
get picked up by American broadcasters
because of the strike and the longer the
strike goes on the more of that you'll
see this time around with the two sides
far apart job action could last even
longer
jeopardizing The Fall TV season leaving
audiences and actors at a loss for words
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
a serious parcel is now in the hands of
the BC SPCA a cat who arrived at the
Vancouver International mail center
inside a box originating from China
this is precious cargo as named by the
SPCA she was discovered inside a damaged
box with a sizable hole a Canada Border
Services Agency officer looked inside
and saw a pair of eyes staring back it's
unclear how long the cat spent in
transit but she was vaccinated and she
was given medical attention and she is
now recovering in a foster home
unexpected drama outside Buckingham
Palace
coming up what triggered a lockdown with
four days until the king's coronation
to breaking news in London where
Buckingham Palace is in lockdown days
before the king's coronation police say
they arrested a man carrying a knife
outside the palace grounds after he
allegedly threw what's believed to be
shotgun cartridges over the fence police
also detonated a suspicious bag found in
his possession they're treating this as
a mental health incident the king and
queen consort were not at the palace
Security will be a challenge for King
Charles this week
today he met with British MPS before a
video call with prime minister Justin
Trudeau
tens of thousands of people will line
the Streets of London to catch a glimpse
at the newly crowned King but in the UK
many have mixed feelings about the
monarchy particularly in this day and
age our Redmond Shannon hit the streets
to find out whether people will or won't
celebrate this weekend
some of the londoners enjoying the
spring sunshine on Primrose Hill are
sitting on the fence about the
coronation
yeah I'm not anti-wallist I don't mind
the Royals you know would if you know if
someone said would you get rid of them
I'd probably say no
a recent poll suggested that
three-quarters of Britain's under 25
care little or not at all for what
happens this weekend I think I'll give
it like you know maybe a watch like over
a few minutes as someone who does
struggle with money and stuff like that
I just try to ignore it because I don't
like to carry negative kind of like
opinions on someone when I don't know
too much the UK has changed immensely
since Queen Elizabeth's coronation the
country is now far more diverse than it
was 70 years ago hey I have work B I
don't care King Charles can do what you
want so I just don't care the Royals
have no bearing on my life they're just
there for decoration really so yeah
don't care what they do I suppose they
stop spending taxpayers money older
immigrants I spoke with from former
European colonies are more open to
watching this weekend some are even
forgiving about the painful past of
crown and Empire it is something that's
a long time ago I wasn't born my dad
wasn't born at the time you know we know
the history whatever it is you know
Antoinette from Cameroon can barely wait
for the weekend I love them
an adoration that extends to Facebook
reels of Prince William all rooted in
gratitude for her life in Britain in
Africa if you haven't got that
opportunity
opinions toward the new King in London
are as diverse and numerous as the sites
the sounds and the tastes on the city's
busy streets Redmond Shannon double news
London
and Global News will have special
coverage of the king's coronation on
Saturday Donna friezman will be live in
London at 5 a.m Eastern 2 A.M Pacific
right here on global
[Music]
I had the push for the king to renounce
a 15th century Doctrine
[Music]
as the coronation of King Charles
approaches some groups are renewing
calls for the king to renounce the
doctrine of Discovery a nearly 500 year
old papal decree used to justify
colonial rule it was recently renounced
by the pope himself and is Nita Garcia
reports some see the king's a session to
the throne as an opportunity for him to
do the same
but look how low the snow still is Chief
Dalton silver looks out onto his
nation's unseated lands with hopes for
the future the Flesh and Blood of our
ancestors is everywhere and the
connections we have to these lands
need to be recognized and it needs to
come from the crown he feels King
Charles needs to take responsibility for
a centuries-old concept used by European
monarchs to justify colonization of
indigenous lands the doctrine of
Discovery was recently repudiated by the
Vatican if we still operate I think
under the shadow of that Doctrine how
can we not feel that we're being treated
as lesser than I see a lot of money
being spent on this coronation but is it
really necessary as a member of the
indigenous delegation to the Vatican
last year pixie Wells advocated for Pope
Francis to take action towards
reconciliation and says the crown has a
role to play as well the royal family
have a lot to do with the indigenous
people and substance use Wells wants to
see King Charles take similar steps as
the Pope in visiting indigenous
territories and apologizing for the
generational harms caused do we know if
we have the bags of red dresses
connecting to my call teacher has
completely saved my life what would you
like to see immediately from King
Charles in the royal family we need more
cultural centers our people need housing
this is actually at his Cottage Robert
watt met then Prince Charles in 2016 as
part of an Inuit group visiting Wales to
learn about language preservation for me
he was very genuinely interested I just
hope that he listens to what we are
requesting
This Is Our Land
that needs to be recognized for silver a
residential school survivor it's a
reckoning around the institutions of
assimilation the honor of the crown
is in question until we come to a place
where we feel we're being treated
equally he says it's an important moment
for the crown to take leadership in
advancing indigenous rights change which
could shape the Monarch's influence on
communities like his for generations to
come nitugarsha global news near
Abbotsford BC
sure
[Music]
next the tributes pouring in for
Canadian musician Gordon Lightfoot and a
look back at his extraordinary life
[Music]
I want to take a moment first to
remember Gordon Lightfoot one of
Canada's greatest songwriters and just
an extraordinary Canadian icon
he loved this country with an incredible
deep passion and it's extraordinarily
humble about it as well
prime minister Justin Trudeau paid
tribute to Gordon Lightfoot today the
Canadian folk music legend died
yesterday in a Toronto hospital he was
84 years old
Lightfoot was one of a kind his impact
on music and other artists immeasurable
his enduring hit songs and passionate
storytelling created devoted fans from
all around the world and that has never
stopped tonight he has the top six
downloads on iTunes a pretty incredible
feat for anyone Mike trolllay now on the
man who drew from his roots and became a
legend
here he is Gordon Lightfoot by 1969
Gordon Lightfoot was a Bonafide star on
both sides of the Atlantic
but he wasn't convinced
in the early morning rain until he heard
Elvis on the radio covering Gordon
Lightfoot
in the 1960s Canada didn't have much of
a star system Joni Mitchell and Neil
Young made it big by moving to the U.S
Gordon Lightfoot followed but only
lasted two years in Los Angeles before
returning home to Canada but I don't
think it suited him so when he came back
into Canada seemingly full time he never
lost that step in what it was like to be
able to write about Canada to write
about the Canadian railroad system to
write about the highways and the valleys
and the rivers
to his fans his songwriting was prolific
for him it was therapeutic in truth it
was the the only Refuge at one point
always was it it's got me through
breakups of relationships and marriages
and everything he wrote what's
considered a part of the Canadian
identity in The Wreck of the Edmund
Fitzgerald
foreign
pop culture name checked on Seinfeld I
love Edmund Fitzgerald's voice no Gordon
Lightfoot was the singer Edmund
Fitzgerald was the ship
in truth it's hard to measure the
breadth of his influence but clearly his
songwriting lingered in the minds of
authors singers astronauts and comedians
Canada lost part of itself wrote Keith
for Sutherland adding he lost a hero you
could my
Christmas days Canada's barred lived to
perform
and so he sits in bronze in his hometown
of Aurelia cross-legged guitar in hand
the sounds of a country pouring from his
heart
microwave Global News
Ms global national for this Tuesday
night that at you which stands four
meters high is called Golden Leaves it
depicts lyrics from some of the singer's
most beloved songs
thanks for watching tonight
that's what you get for loving me
I ain't the kind you hang around
with any new love that I find
cause moving in my stocking trade I'm
moving on
I won't think of you when I'm gone